Isis's princess cookie Nestle's oh I
thought it was gonna be I'm like I've
seen the cookie I'm like okay but
where's the princess cut is an episode
this cookie holds up whatever there was
like a 7-eleven type place and it's I
just want the opening to do it like the
helicopters the hostages go I just
you don't think in the budget I would
start out that way oh and the cookie
wants Bubblegum's crown because when he
was a little kid he really looked up to
rein love that she was a princess so he
said he wanted to be a princess and she
just laughed cuz he's a boy and stuff
like that and he got it just as he put
it messed him up
and so he's holding these him inist
which is hilarious I love it the chips
I'll have you know identities and stuff
are holding up the place and Jake feels
really bad for him so he decides he's
gonna help him escape and be his own
kind of princess and gets away the
cookie tries to commit suicide but
forgets he's a cookie and he just
crumbles if they put it back together I
clogged up my palm and a loony bin but
Jacobs and dresses a mail bag because he
said he wanted to be a mailman
originally anyway it gives him a little
princess crown and everybody is saying
this I love is like princess cookie and
he's happy
oh that's fun I like that sort of well
swishy because i think that kind of
those shouted misunderstandings like I
love kids they're like oh whatever they
get over and move on but there are some
kids that like they just let stuff
faster you know I'd stay with I'm like
you know and let it define up and stuff
like that so what carts against your bad
what nothing doing
you put me down that's a car that cards
against humanity' okay we're gonna be
low five five okay oh now girls gonna
wonder what that story is but there is
actually no story or is there you have
to find out yeah
Oh see where they take cats come on
internet take it somewhere yes
conspiracy theory bow oh and but no I
liked it I liked the I liked Fitness the
shadow I thought was very funny Tim
going as a milkman alone the milkman
okay give the hostages ok give a milk
yeah I like the acting from that guy
scrubs guy what would you call black
scrubs flux ropes that's from I got that
from Family Guy cuz I think Peters like
I want to see black scrubs and I think
he was very funny
I liked Jake wanting to help a guy out I
like that he just wanted to sort of
follow his dream and he knows he's
screwed up and everything but he's like
it just for a guy and they're such nice
give Jake a little bit more humanity may
not be as manatee but it's you know nice
to see him it you like want to help a
guy out you know it just not sold terms
I like here that fit saving someone but
like or against us so yeah I like to
find if I was a lot of fun joint oh I
liked it I have to say this is probably
the very first episode where I actually
really liked to Jake um like I really
liked Jake I normally see Jake is either
just kind of there or as a ruby asshole
and I thought it was the one episode and
I really appreciated it where Jake
empathized actually empathized with
someone and you know and and I can see
both sides you know it happened long ago
get the fuck over it it doesn't give you
the right you know to take hostages and
stuff but on the other hand you know
again because they bubblegum so hard you
know again it's like you saying you do
things and not just bubblegum but people
in general you say and do things that
you don't even think about that you
don't realize is is harming people is
hurting people it's damaging them 100
kids I mean
kids especially it's hard to figure out
whether or not this is really gonna mess
up exactly it's like you can be anything
you want
okay I'll be this new hold on I'd like
to just take this really quickly all she
did was laugh when he said it she didn't
say no she didn't say you can't you
didn't say you were a boy sure she left
that that was it but the implications
yeah but that's the thing though again
no pun intended but are we supposed to
handle kids with kid gloves
I mean are we not able to laugh when
they say something or could potentially
be damaging them you know everything is
potentially damaged funny lame excuse
well I think that's the point is that
anything and everything is potentially
damaging that's why we have to be more
aware of our actions
bullcrap but you just saying that but PB
may be the right one Ryder's gonna
commit suicide because you know they
work very hard on it be careful with
what you're saying I'm sorry I I guess
yeah be careful with what you say but
how careful do you really need to be
it's like yeah because once we start
going down that route then we're only
gonna be able to say hi well I think
with everything I mean a majority of
extremes if I do not work out but you
see I didn't say all extremes does that
mean extreme times he names strangers
times where you don't um but majority of
times is trying to find that balance and
it's like that's exactly what you have
to do I mean there's no like
mathematical equation here's how you
raise a kid
here's what screw it out there what
won't if this kid has these conditions
and this will not screw them up and it's
even kids I have certain conditions
whatever like X does not always equal Z
there's always things that you know
other anomalies and stuff so it's like
you never know
so yeah it's always like be caught it I
always say because just do your best you
know and again I don't think bubblegum
was being a bitch or being evil she
normally if you hear a voice hello our
child our son don't him well yeah
I was really young he you know he was
into kind of girlier things and we were
like oh my god this would totally be gay
but that's the thing it's like he was
like oh I totally want to do this like
yeah we're finding that we didn't we
don't care in either way but we just
kind of chuckled at it and yeah but I
never laughed at him in his it's his
face yeah we did I laughed I laughed at
him behind his back a lot mother
Corsi know what I'm saying is that this
guy held a bunch of people hostage
because bubblegum chuckled that's it she
did you like something I evil laugh and
go oh sure there's a lot more to it than
that
I'm sure God didn't know about it he was
in an orphanage stuff he was in an
orchard a local goods we're depressed
okay okay we're going way too far with
this I want to bring up at least two
things one you want a goal yet and yes
they were in the background just staring
a job down there Justin but it's like
that's not exactly how I wanted to see
him I love seeing the back there like I
was saying well like I wanted to say
with the last episode where I read with
lumpy space was actually writing and
it's actually real like it's actually
what's going on again it's a small nods
like that and have a goal yet still in
the background that I think are just
wonderful I love that stuff I also loved
how there's a little nuts like Thelma
and Louise yeah I was getting two with
the clamp and yeah let's just keep going
keep going but no cookie was holding
people hostage hostages and in the end
that's a crime you don't just let them
go it's it's as simple as that I like
that they put them in in its
toosha I like that better than going to
jail no that's fine no that's actually
perfectly fine because you know damn
well if BRE was in that convenience
store being held hostage by someone who
just wanted the crown oh he'll leave and
never come back I know you'd be like
kill him you turn the peoples in say
this is all your fault somehow yes kill
them right in front of people's see what
you did
Wow Oh getting darker and darker today I
was gonna go back to the childhood no
was it just me or when the little
chocolate chip once in the one room and
there was that glowing yeah but it
wasn't a glowworm but that's what made
it made me think of glowworms remember
those words that glue that glue globe oh
yeah yeah I wonder if that was a nod to
that or not said V yeah I had to fall I
had to because my mom was like Jack
maybe I like to girly toys again I liked
glowworms
I watched my little pony so going full
circle just cuz you like girly things
insoluble chocolate and for liking it
doesn't mean you should go on some
psychotic rampage and hold people huh
convenience store we will teach them
well tonight girly things nice you can
do it let's just don't black him on the
news
yeah look there he is oh he might be
more famous than you that can't happen
not anymore he's yeah I see his head is
there now and his body's over there no
your wizard eyes are cooking you know I
think you're just insane oh why am i
talk to you you talked about sleep
people's throats I know you have to talk
to me my nose